la ligne ter minassian professeur
d'histoire contemporaine de la russie et
du caucase à l'institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales est
aussi directrice de l'observatoire des
états post soviétiques
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france quel est le but de
cette visite du premier ministre
arménien à moscou alors qu'on sait qu'il
est qu'il a annoncé démissionner le but
de cette visite il a été annoncé par la
voie officielle il a été annoncé en
effet que poutine est pas chine et en
discuterons donc cet après midi des
actions visant à résoudre les problèmes
durent à la barre d'une part ce qui est
évidemment un vaste problème mais plus
précisément du rétablissement ou plutôt
de l'établissement de liens économiques
et de transport dans le temps le caucase
du sud qui reviendrait dans un instant
et puis le second volet officiel qui est
annoncé c'est l'intention d'aborder le
la question du développement du
partenariat et de l'alliance stratégique
arméno-russe le tout dans dans un bain
dans un cadre bilatéral
donc cet entretien intervient comme l'a
rappelé votre journaliste dans un
contexte politique extrêmement complexe
est en fait pour tout dire même
carrément chaotique pour l arménie où la
démission de pachinian a été annoncée
par lui-même mais elle n'est pas encore
actée pour courant avril ouvrant ainsi
la voie à des élections mais cette
démission était une des missions
techniques qui n'a rien à voir avec le
fait que sa politique qu'il se sente
responsable de doune politique qui n'a
quand même pas été extrêmement brillante
c'est une des missions techniques de
laquelle il espère être reconduit au
pouvoir
donc c'est très important de noter
d'abord le cadre bilatéral dans lequel
un entretien enfin intervient sept
cet entretien excusez-moi d'autres
formats ont été expérimentés notamment
en trilatérale puisqu'elle a un groupe
de travail trilatérale qui inclut
l'azerbaïdjan notamment depuis le 11
janvier 2021 et dans un contexte
évidemment
beaucoup plus tendue pourquoi est-ce que
vous excusez moi vous interromps
pourquoi est-ce que vous parlez de
démission tomic que c'est parce qu'il a
annoncé qu'ils seraient qu'il resterait
un par intérim jusqu'aux élections
anticipées de joie c'est une des
missions techniques parce que cette île
est nécessaire dans le système
constitutionnel actuel de l'arménie que
le premier ministre donne sa démission
pour que des élections anticipées
puissent être pu être organisée ensuite
donc donc voilà c'est ça n'est pas une
démission définitive de sa barre enfin
il n'annonce pas par là son intention de
quitter le pouvoir si c'est si c'est le
sens à votre question donc c'est un
contexte en réalité extrêmement ambiguë
oui mais je vous permet de continuer
vous avez interrompu sur la relation
donc d'être contre les rapports
qu'entretiennent les deux pays et les
enjeux de cette journée vous pourrez
bien sûr alors les enjeux de cette
rencontre en fait ces îles sont ils ont
été annoncés il ya tout d'abord la
question des corridors dans le règlement
du conflit du haut karabagh puisque la
question des voies de communication et
donc de l'échangé entre guillemets entre
le corridor de latchine ou où l'ex
corridor de latchine qui établit la
liaison entre le haut à la barre et le
territoire arménien qui est actuellement
un corridor qui est surveillé par les
forces de maintien de la paix de la
fédération de russie
et puis l'autre corridor celui qui est
projeté entre l'azerbaïdjan et son ex
clave du nakhitchevan alors ça c'est un
point absolument cruciale c'est le
fameux points 9 de l'accord du cessez le
feu
et bien entendu c'est là où le bât
blesse car ce corridor
s'il venait à être établie comme cela
est prévu dans l'accord de cessez le feu
va donc établir une continuité entre
l'azerbaïdjan son ex-club du
nakhitchevan et et la turquie et tout
cela donc fragilise terriblement le
territoire du sud et qu'on appelle le
anglaise où tout le ou le sionisme et
c'est donc dans cette région justement
que le pouvoir de pachinian et bien
entendu fragilisé parce qu'un certain
nombre de deux mères aux deux
municipalités lui reproche d'être une
sorte de bradeurs de territoire puisque
le le corridor passerait au travers ou
tout au moins au sud 2-2 ce territoire
vraisemblablement le long de la
frontière arméno iranienne le long de la
vallée de l'alzou pour l'instant il n'ya
rien mais enfin il ya enfin une ancienne
voie de chemin de fer et qui pourrait
constituer justement un axe de
communication majeur donc la nôtre la
samba de gens et merci beaucoup talina
termine à sion pour toutes ces
précisions
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire contemporaine de la russie et
du caucase à l'institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales mais
aussi directrice de l'observatoire des
états postsoviétiques merci pour toutes
vos précisions